This video is brought to you by ground news.
What's up, why's crack Jared here.
You might've noticed that nobody can agree on what a reliable news sources
people have been accusing the news of getting worse, more partisan,
more divisive, more alert.
And as people accused news outlets of slant spin bias or outright fake news,
it's worth asking, can the news ever be truly impartial?
And where did the idea of objective news even come from?
So today we're going to see if we can answer these questions in this wisecrack
condition on can the news be objective before we begin?
I want to give a shout out to this week's sponsor.
Ground news ground is run by a small team of seven Canadian independent industry
outsiders with the mission of fighting against the rise of misinformation,
sensationalism and bias news.
It's an app that allows you to see the same news story as covered by every news
outlet from the far left to the far right.
And everything in between on the political spectrum bias is clearly labeled for
every new source using bias ratings from independent nonprofit monitoring
agencies in a world where objectivity is hard to define much less find
ground news,
lets you come to your own conclusions by showing you the perspectives and takes
from a wide range of news media.
Check out news from over 40,000 local national and foreign news outlets and be
aware of the diverse opinions and straight up BS that other people around you
will be sharing with you over awkward conversations.
The app is free to download and is available on iOS and Android.
And now back to the show it's worth defining objectivity very quickly.
So we're going to use Merriam Webster's definition of objectivity,
which is the lack of favoritism toward one side or another and freedom from
bias. In other words,
to report the news subjectively means to recount the goings on in the world
without a specific agenda to promote or a favorite politician to support.
We also need to figure out where the idea of objective news comes from because
it's a fairly modern phenomenon for most of Western history, print publications,
like pamphlets were just another method of the King or landowner passing down,
whatever he wanted his subjects to know or a method for the church to
communicate with the faithful.
But this started changing in the 18th century as the philosophies of the
enlightenment work, their ways into all aspects of culture,
including news publications,
just as artists and scientists use the enlightenment principle of reason to
explore the world untethered from God in the aristocracy.
So two did news publications that sprung up to offer accounts of social and
political affairs.
And this offered a new perspective on the role of objectivity in the press as
the same enlightenment principles that tried to understand the natural world
without bias were used to understand society or so they thought
philosopher,
Terry Eagleton has discussed the complicated early days of the free press in his
book, the function of criticism,
which begins with an account of two of the earliest English papers,
the spectator and the Tatler. According to Eagleton,
both of these papers used moral correction and secure ridicule to offer
criticisms of the aristocracy that would have previously gotten writers locked
in a dungeon at first glance,
it would seem like this new freedom would an objective type of journalism that
could inform regular citizens about current Vince. But according to Eagleton,
these publications were far from objective. And in fact,
they largely serve the purpose of the emerging bourgeoisie while creating an
acceptable way to offer criticisms of the ruling class.
What was even capable of being said,
Eagle to note was defined by England's ruling block.
The very ability to participate in the disinterested debate of English papers
usually meant that one had to be a landowner too. Ironically,
that only those with an interest can be disinterested. In other words,
the debate disagreements and coverage of these patients,
we're all predicated on people who were impacted partially trying to grease the
wheels of the society that kept them and their fellow landowners.
On top while Eagleton was looking back in time at England's press in the 17
hundreds philosopher,
Soren Kierkegaard offered harsh criticism of Copenhagen's press that emerged
during his lifetime a hundred years later.
But while Eagleton was critical of the European press for failing to offer a
truly objective perspective on current events,
Kierkegaard was critical of the papers and Copenhagen for being too objective.
One of here regards key philosophic.
Well tenants was that truth is subjectivity,
which for him meant that for anything to be true,
it had to elicit passion and commitment.
Now that might sound a little bit strange.
So follow with me for a bit in terms of journalism,
Kierkegaard thought that the lack of subjectivity in the press created a lack of
passion and intensity in the public and led to an age of passion lists,
reflection where people would rather observe what was happening around them.
Then take any active role in it.
One of the effects of the supposedly objective press,
according to Kierkegaard was that everyone reading the papers became one big
anonymous group called the public.
The news just became a forum of general entertainment describing the world in a
pseudo objective way. Now, if this all sounds a little bit abstract,
we can consider the work of John Stewart as the host of the daily show.
Jon Stewart embodied the opposite of the press.
That Kierkegaard hated so much precisely because he operated in a mode of
subjectivity as writer, Matt Taibbi put it in the New York times,
some object to the characterization of Stewart as a journalist because he has
opinions and isn't objective.
But those people aren't to be taken seriously opinion.
Can't be extracted from reporting.
The only question is whether or not it's hidden Tybee points out that
objectivity is a guise. The press can hide behind to avoid responsibility.
Unlike CNN's marketing initiative to put facts.
First steward operated in a mode of pure subjectivity,
letting his audience know his biases upfront and breaking from the humor of his
show to get passionate about issues.
He cared about like healthcare for nine 11 first responders.
It's not that facts don't exist,
but simply hiding behind the facts to distance yourself from your own bias is
well bad.
So if Kierkegaard pointed all this out in the 19th century and Eagleton expands
on it over 35 years ago,
why are we still so hung up on the promise of an objective of journalism?
The idea of objectivity in American journalism largely comes from the work of
Walter Lippmann,
a 20th century journalists and media critic who thought that journalists needed
to incorporate the scientific method into their reporting.
Litman thought that by presenting citizens with this more impartial news,
that they would be better informed and the democratic process would be
strengthened while Littmann seems to have been.
Well-intentioned the reason that objectivity in the news became so popular in
the 20th century, had little to do with democratic aspirations. Instead,
the real driving force behind the push toward objectivity in the American media
was America's most famous pastime advertising because as the press grew into a
full fledged industry, advertising became the largest source of media revenue.
Today's news today,
rodeos bar camel cigarettes by NBC.
Having a narrow audience with a specific political slant was a business
liability.
If a newspaper only focused on offering a socialist perspective on political
events in some mid-sized city advertisers weren't interested or worse a
paper with the opposite viewpoint might spring up and take away half of your
market share media scholar, Gerald bolt,
asking notes that 19th century advertisers wanted less criticism of public
officials and reminded publishers that partisanship hurts circulation and
consequently advertising revenues.
Even if you had a widely read paper with a specific political leaning that
leaning,
might've also scared away advertisers dooming your business from the get-go as
noted by Edward S. Herman and Noam Chomsky in their book, manufacturing consent,
plenty of papers throughout history were more widely read than their allegedly
more objective competitors.
But a lack of advertising meant they were either put out of business or bought
by their rivals flushed with ad dollars. And once that happened,
their coverage began to resemble the ad friendly coverage of their parent
company.
So offering an objective perspective became codeword for keeping everything
vanilla for the widest audience possible it's much like Kierkegaard predicted
that the press would turn individuals into one big anonymous public.
And in this case,
the anonymous public is made up of consumers who can make money for both new
sources and their advertisers. This connection between journalism and commerce.
Shouldn't be surprising in light of our 24 hour news cycle where people like CNN
head,
Jeff sucker have no problem acknowledging that the network is primarily offering
entertainment, even comparing it to sports.
Things are a little different than when manufacturing consent was written in
1988 for one mainstream media has splintered into conservative outlets like Fox
news and liberal outlets like CNN. But the basic principles are still there.
Newspapers and media outlets are selling a product to advertisers and that
product is you. So while Fox news is appealing to a conservative base,
they want to appeal to the widest conservative base.
They can and hopefully attract high earners among that base we'll drop money on
their advertisers products.
CNN similarly wants to attract a wide audience while not alienating their
well-to-do viewers who are so lucrative to their bottom line.
Manufacturing consent argued a series of filters defined what kinds of stories
corporate media could report on and how one of those filters was simply
corporate ownership. For instance, the head of GE, which owned NBC at the time,
told the news chief not to use the term black Monday to describe the stock
market crash of 1987,
as it could depress the value of GE stock broadcast a story.
And Eric bar now recounts how a documentary series on environmental problems was
unable to find the sponsors necessary for its production because it was critical
of corporations. And if you think much has changed,
consider the recent story that Bloomberg killed a piece about China's elite,
for fear,
they'd be shut out of the Chinese market and who could forget vice-president of
East coast, television and microwave oven programming for GE Jack Donaghy. Okay,
that one's a joke because the news media is dependent on advertising money to
make profits.
They directly benefit by serving the political and financial interests of the TV
networks and corporate entities that pay their bills,
even when covering less hot button issues.
If coverage of a story will alienate the board of directors or worse.
The marketing department at Johnson and Johnson adjustments will be made.
And according to Herman and Chomsky,
much of what we are served as objective news is just propaganda for the
powerful.
They determined that they select the shade they control.
They restrict in order to serve the interests,
dominant elite groups in the society.
It's not that journalists are bad and plenty of journalists do amazing and
important work,
but many of them have to work through the constraints of news as business.
So do we just forget objectivity Brent Cunningham,
the managing editor of the Columbia journalism review thinks that a
reconsideration of the value of objectivity can provide a window into a
particular failure of the press,
allowing the principle of objectivity to make us passive recipients of the news
rather than aggressive analyzers and explainers of it.
While we started with the question, can the news be objective?
It seems like the better question might be,
do we actually want the news to be objective in the first place to which we'd
likely answer? Probably not. At least not the way most people think about it,
whether it's at the risk of ideology being smuggled into our news or losing our
ability to critically look at information provided to us,
it seems like facts alone won't save us.
It might be better instead of feeling safe and secure with your new source of
choice to ask whose interests are they serving?
How are they filtering their stories?
What kind of stories are not being reported?
Are they upfront about their own biases, but what do you guys think?
Let us know in the comments,
thanks to all of our amazing patrons for supporting the channel and our podcasts
and I'll catch you next time. And before you go,
I'd like to give one last shout out to ground news for sponsoring this video
with over 40,000 independent and mainstream sources from all across the
political spectrum. Brown news brings you the news perspectives.
You're not seeing for an ad free and transparent news reading experience.
Download ground news today by clicking the link in the description,
the app is free to download and is available on iOS and Android. And as always,
thanks for watching guys.
Peace
[inaudible].